blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman welcome everybody you know we are
really
starting to do it we are really seeing
in the united states and
increasingly around the world that we
are pointed to
an exit from this global pandemic for
many people it already feels like it is
over
statistically medically it is getting
closer and closer to being over
and we knew we suspected we said
it was written in the fall that
the societal and cultural end to the
pandemic would likely come before
what we would call the medical end which
is we are back to
sort of baseline risk of death from
being in the world
globally we are not there yet and many
countries are very far from that
but let's start with what we can say
that is going well
and then we'll talk about the things
that are still the question marks
coronavirus cases in the united states
are now down 95
from a peak of 255 000 new cases per day
in january down to about 13
000 cases per day unfortunately
we are seeing some spikes among
unvaccinated people i'm going to talk
about that
momentarily shocker right the people who
are not vaccinated are still getting the
virus
but more on that in a bit but a 95
decline overall is a great start now
what about deaths
with deaths we are seeing the numbers
come down
relatively quickly once again deaths
peaked in late january
around 3 500 a day and are now down
to about 350 a day that is a decline
of about 90 in terms of daily coveted
deaths
for comparison because again
we may now feel that it's not safe until
we are at zero risk
we're never going to be at zero risk
life doesn't have zero risk the question
is
when are we back to baseline risk in a
normal flu season in the united states
just on average
about 110 people die per day now
sometimes we have a really bad flu
season
and 250 people die a day but in an
average flu season there's 110
flu deaths per day we're now at 350
coveted deaths per day so we're not
down to what we might call baseline
background risk
but we're getting closer and closer to
that
if we look around the world the numbers
are also looking better and better
global cases are down 55
from their peak at one point we were
seeing 830
000 new coveted cases per day we're down
more than half
to about 375 000 cases per day still a
long way to go
but more than half reduced and then
global deaths are down about
40 percent global daily deaths peaked at
more than 14 000 in january
almost peak there again in early april
now down to about
9 000 deaths a day from covet globally
still a giant number
but declining more and more now in a
moment we're going to talk about the
growth in cases among unvaccinated
people
but before we get to that the new issue
floating around
is that of the delta variant which is
floating around uh tomorrow we're going
to be joined by dr ashish jaw from brown
university and we will talk to him about
the delta variant as well as a number of
other
issues but what is the deal with the
delta variant so the delta variant is
indeed more transmissible
more and more cases in many countries
are coming from the delta variant so
even if in the
in the aggregate cases are going down
more and more of the cases we are seeing
are the delta variant if you are fully
vaccinated
you really don't have much to worry
about especially if you're in a highly
vaccinated area bob wechter
who's the chair of the ucsf department
of medicine had a good twitter thread
about this where he wrote quote
i know everybody's sick of playing
three-dimensional coven chess
sorry but the delta variant forces us
back
to the chess board ergo this thread if
you're fully vaxxed i wouldn't be too
worried
especially if you're in a highly vast
region if you're not vaccinated i'd be
afraid
maybe even very afraid why let's start
with the things we know about the
current situation
then layer in new information about the
delta aka indian
variant then we'll end with what i'd
suggest you and we do
the current u.s situation is good cases
hospitalization deaths are falling fast
largely due to our fabulous vaccines in
san francisco where he works
with 70 of those over age 12 fully
vaccinated we're nearly in a
post-covered world this is a doctor
saying this everybody's opening up
including on tuesday today california
that's fine
for now sadly half of the u.s
aged over 12 remains unvaccinated and in
certain states mostly southern and
rightly
leaning it's more like two-thirds that
are unvaccinated we know
that a small number of vaccinated people
will get breakthrough infections but
they'll rarely get very sick
and will almost never die of covid
so still you know we have to balance
the people who never wanted to take any
precaution
and there were many of them and for a
long time the former president was one
of them
with the doom and gloomers who were
still saying
don't go out open nothing work from home
only
no kids in schools masks everywhere
everything is dangerous we can never
ever ever take our masks off
we've got to balance that and the
balance at balancing act
is the vaccines work really well
against all the variants including the
delta variant
if you're fully vaccinated meaning the
requisite number of days beyond your
last dose whether it's two doses or one
and we bolster that safety
by being around people who are
vaccinated there are now states
in the 70 80 percent vaccinated range
for those who are
eligible your risk there of any variant
is going to be dramatically lower than
if you are in a place
where only 35 or 40 percent of the
population is vaccinated it is merely
math and so all of this is mostly common
sense
tomorrow we will speak to dr ashish jaw
more specifically about the variants
and how to interpret vaccine efficacy
numbers
but it shouldn't shock us that although
the big picture is looking better and
better
cases are rising again among the
unvaccinated
let's talk about that next who would
have guessed
who would have guessed that if you get
vaccinated
you're very unlikely to catch the
coronavirus because the vaccines are so
effective
but that if you're unvaccinated
especially if there's lots of
unvaccinated people around you
and you're around them indoors without
masks
for extended periods of time you are
more likely to get sick if a more
transmissible variant comes forward
and that is exactly what is going on
right now
a new washington post report coronavirus
infections dropping
where people are vaccinated rising where
they are not
and the article goes into detail to tell
us something that
i mean it who would this be a shock to
right
states with higher vaccination rates now
have markedly fewer coronavirus cases
makes sense as infections are dropping
in places where most residents have been
immunized
and are rising in many places where
people have not a washington post
analysis has found
states with lower vaccination also have
significantly higher hospitalization
rates
poorly vaccinated communities have not
been reporting catastrophic conditions
instead they're usually seeing new
infections holding steady
or increasing without overwhelming local
hospitals
as recently as 10 days ago vaccination
rates did not predict the difference in
covet cases
but immunization rates have diverged and
case counts in highly vaccinated states
are dropping quickly
vaccination is not even within each
state the post found the connection
between vaccine shots and coveted cases
at the local level comparing more than
100 counties with
low vaccination meaning under 20
vaccinated
and more than 700 counties with high
vaccination
meaning at least 40 vaccinated and
here is the here are the findings and
we're displaying them graphically for
you
counties with high vaccination have low
coveted rates that are going down
in counties where few people are
vaccinated not only are there higher
case rates but the number of cases is
also growing
this is in the absolute this is really
important to understand
if you look at places with fewer
vaccinations and more cases
and you see cases above the national
average these are places like
wyoming idaho alabama louisiana
arkansas west virginia indiana missouri
what do these places have in common i
think you understand politically what's
going on there
you then look at the lower right
quadrant on this graph that we're
showing our audience the places with
more vaccinations
have fewer cases places like vermont
massachusetts hawaii connecticut new
jersey rhode island new hampshire
pennsylvania california maryland
dc what do these places have in common
well politically they're very blue
now there are a few outliers there are
some places with more vaccinations
and also more cases uh the there's
really four states in that quadrant
colorado oregon washington and maine
we're still trying to figure out why
that is
and uh we we we don't we don't yet know
um so the takeaway here of course is
go and get yourself vaccinated it's it's
really that simple
if you want to protect yourself and
others go and get yourself
vaccinated and you know the the doom and
gloom
uh is correct in unvaccinated
communities
a 60 more transmissible variant which is
what we believe the delta slash indian
variant uh to be at this point in time
is going to burn its way through a
population
as it finds people who are not
vaccinated when you are vaccinated
because the vaccines are so effective
not only is it less likely i mean
how are we even saying this now in june
of 2021
you are less likely to get sick and
people around you are less likely to get
sick because the vaccine does not
guarantee immunity it is not 100
effective
we all do something for our community
when we get ourselves vaccinated so
shocking right who could have seen it
coming
that the places that are more vaccinated
are doing better
than the places that are not now as more
international travel resumes
spain hazar is about to open italy has
or is about to open france has opened
uh to vaccinated people etc will
vaccinated
travel to countries that are not yet as
vaccinated as the united states
will that increase rates uh i believe
that it will not
because vaccination is mostly happening
fast enough in
the majority of those countries uh that
things are going to remain
under control nothing that's happening
is surprising and
i see people you know people on the left
and on the right posting
things to to twitter and to facebook etc
as if
anything other than what we're seeing
was predictable the place is getting
vaccinated quickly particularly when you
get to 50
cases drop like a lead balloon places
that are not are going to continue
getting sick particularly as these
variants
spread no no surprise just simply no
surprise
tell me what you're seeing in your neck
of the woods you can find me on twitter
at dpakman
we have a huge show for you today
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show is primarily and
most importantly
funded by you guys and you know i had
i'll actually talk a little bit later i
i
had some interesting conversations
lately with some other
fellow progressive hosts about some of
the drama that's
that's going on within the progressive
media community which i'll get into
later
and one of the things we all sort of
came together around was
aren't our communities just great like
is it isn't it incredible
that while there are so many of these
left-wing communities being ripped apart
by internal
drama that we some of us have been able
to build these communities that are
self-sustaining
where the viewers and the listeners are
supporting the work we do
which gives us incredible freedom that
so many
people in media dream of having and
never achieve
so thank you and you can sign up today
at joinpacman.com we have a discount
code better21
use it at your at your pleasure uh
and we um make that available to anybody
who wants it coupon code better21
at joinpakman.com you know one of the
things i've said before
and that i continue to say many things
i continue to say one is we can have
political disagreements with our leaders
as we will inevitably
uh have while recognizing that some
leaders
are normal and others are not
and joe biden despite not doing nearly
everything i want him to do
has brought back a degree of respect to
the united states globally
that donald trump only ever dreamed of
and this has become
so clear during the recent g7
and nato summit and joe biden's
various meetings with world leaders
remember that under donald trump world
leaders
were regularly visibly annoyed with
trump
endlessly frustrated with trump trump
was increasingly just not a part of
important conversations that world
leaders
were having the reporting from the g7
and nato is stunning how quickly
respect has been restored to the office
now that doesn't mean biden's a hero
i've said so many times let's not deify
politicians they're just people and
they're flawed people
they're really just like you and me it
doesn't mean biden is a hero
it's just a reminder of how disastrous
the four years under donald trump were
now first of all statistically before we
get to the sort of anecdotal stuff
pew research center released a report
last week documenting
the huge improvement to the united
states stature
globally after the inauguration of joe
biden
and the portion of world citizens from
12 different countries with confidence
in the united states
in the u.s president went from 17
when trump left office now to 75
these these are just stunning numbers
this is basically a
quadrupling of the confidence in the
american president
in these early months of joe biden's
presidency compared to when donald trump
left office
the portion of citizens in these 12
countries with a favorable view of the
united states has nearly doubled from 34
to 62 percent already so statistically
when people like you know the three
people from the my pillow rally say the
us
is now uh you know the we should be
ashamed now
the u.s is embarrassed globally no no no
we we have the data pew research center
studies these this noam chomsky referred
to it a couple weeks ago when we
interviewed him
uh the favorable view of the us has
nearly doubled around the world under
trump but then anecdotally from the g7
and nato
politico describes it as quote overall
the g7 has delivered a significant win
for biden
while the leaders were panned for not
doing enough to vaccinate the world
and frequently fell short of consensus
on the toughest issues
they're definitely moving in the same
direction and other leaders fell over
themselves to welcome biden to their
table
when french president macron was asked
about whether the u.s is
back as a global leader macron said
definitely
and later said it's great to have a u.s
president
part of the club and very willing to
cooperate
german chancellor angela merkel said to
reporters at the summit quote being able
to meet joe biden
is obviously important because he stands
for the commitment to multilateralism
which we were missing in recent years
that's a direct shot at trump
even british prime minister boris
johnson who quite frankly
politically is an adversary of biden as
a right winger
boris johnson said he was quote
absolutely thrilled to see biden
and that speaking to biden was quote a
brush breath of fresh air
heather conley who served as a deputy
assistant secretary of state
to bush cheney's administration said to
politico quote there is no longer a
feeling of complete complete dread
before a nato or g7 summit
or fearing that the meetings would upend
u.s policy
a washington post report added biden was
greeted with delight by g7 leaders
relieved that trump's tantrums
will be replaced by biden's backslapping
so let me say it again
we do not worship politicians on this
show biden is a very flawed politician
and at the end of the day he's just a
person but to deny the clear difference
here is to ignore reality now
obviously and predictably people on the
right are saying
we now are globally embarrassed that's
not backed up by the data but what is
really sad is to see even people on the
left
who see biden not just as not
progressive enough
but who want to go further and they want
to pretend that we don't have a night
and day difference from what we had
under trump
guys it's okay to recognize and still to
say
biden hasn't done enough biden's not
progressive enough
biden may not achieve the things we want
him to that's fine
it's okay to say trump was a reality tv
freak show
and biden is a respectful educated
diplomat and that's a really good thing
but we still hold biden accountable on
policy it's okay to do that
but the leftists who react to this by
saying
of course merkel and boris johnson like
biden
they're all the same center-right
neo-liberal
whatever um biden's
policy platform is not
that of merkel it is not that of johnson
will he achieve everything he said he
was going to no of course not and we'll
hold them accountable won't be critical
but we really participate
in a sort of collective gaslighting if
we and by we i mean others i'm not doing
this if we pretend
that there's no night and day difference
between what trump was
and what president biden is today uh you
know
the thing trump could never buy no
matter how much he spent and no matter
how much money he had
was class and professionalism and
maturity
and uh tact and diplomacy and
that doesn't make biden a progressive
hero
by its very by merely being that way
but it changes dramatically the standing
of the united states
around the world and that's a really
important thing you know we
we spoke uh last week about how many
companies
that were celebrating pride month
have a long history of donating to
homophobic politicians
i want to now follow up on a story that
we talked about
uh some time ago several months ago the
company
boeing has quietly resumed donating
to the republican traders that some know
as the sedition
caucus this is a daily beast article
which outlines what's going on
really well let's take a look at it and
it says after briefly swearing off
political donations in the wake of the
capital riot
boeing is now throwing cash at officials
who fought
to overturn the results of the 2020
election
in a recent filing with the federal
election commission
boeing's political action committee
reported major contributions to three
republican members of congress
who voted to challenge the results of
the electoral college steve scalise
disgusting guy
and then the lesser known vicky hartzler
and jack bergman the report being
boeing's
first to show political contributions
after the assault on the capital
also disclosed a twenty five thousand
dollar gift to the republican attorneys
general association
whose fundraising armed hal arm helped
promote the january 6 rally to quote
stop the steal boeing contributed less
than half that amount
to the organization's democratic
counterpart boeing gave scalise and
hartzler each
5 thousand dollars the limit for an
election bergman
a michigan conservative who in december
pushed erroneous claims of election
fraud in his home state got half of that
amount
boeing previously donated to all three
now the article does go on to say boeing
also gave money to democratic
officials like nancy pelosi as well as
republicans who did vote to certify the
election results
the aerospace and defense giant also
gave the maximum 105
thousand dollars to both parties house
and
senate campaign committees this is what
people really have to understand about
this
first of all the headline is boeing
quietly resumes donating to republican
uh
you know to the sedition caucus i call
them the republican traders
it may be worse than that because boeing
may never really have stopped the
donations to these people and what i
mean by that is
when the january 6th riots happened in
early 2021
obviously 2020 was over so 2020
contributions were done
the 2020 election was over and the 2020
calendar year was also over
now it's 2021 and they are again
making contributions so even to say that
they
stopped them between january and june
when donations are really only now
ramping up and
they've hit their maximums anyway is it
really even fair to say they stopped
anything
because they're donating in june instead
of in february
or march or april or may it's not even
clear to me
that there was anything to the statement
that they were stopping those donations
to these traitorous seditious
individuals
we had this example earlier in the week
specifically about
boeing and about boycotts it's really
hard
to boycott a company like boeing
because for the most part boeing is
number one a defense contractor
and it has nothing to do with sort of
consumer-facing
decisions that we make if we wanted to
boycott boeing as uh airline passengers
we would have to figure out okay let's
see i need to go from new york city to
paris
which airlines are flying airbus planes
or is there some other way that i can
get
to florida without flying on a boeing
airplane it's
really difficult to do this how do you
even boycott boeing and that's part of
what makes this so
pernicious now this is not the only
company that is making donations again
to the uh traitorous treasonous
republicans
pfizer intel ford cigna at t
they've continued to donate to political
action committees that support
many of these republican members of the
house
and senate so to me this is once again a
calculated public relations move
they wanted those initial headlines to
say they are
stopping the donations to people in the
house and senate who supported
stop the steal and may have you know
deliberately or
or implicitly supported the january 6
riots
it's not even clear it ever really even
meant anything
because there are limits on political
donations and okay they waited a few
months
to say that they were paused maybe of no
meaning whatsoever and we've talked
about other
other examples of this last week i had
the story for you about how many
companies that are now saying we
celebrate pride month
um have donated to both
candidates and political action
committees that support candidates
that are homophobic and that have
lobbied against uh gay marriage and
in the you know the days where that was
the fight and now against so-called
religious freedom
to discriminate against people who are
or are perceived to be part of the lgbt
community
we've talked about companies who in the
wake of the george floyd protests around
police brutality
loudly announced we're sending managers
to implicit bias training
which is not even clear really has any
connection whatsoever
to many of the problems that we're
dealing with as far as race goes in the
united states
and it was an obvious and brazen pr move
this is much the same thing and so am i
saying boycott boeing
or don't boycott no i'm not saying
anything about that this is not about
cancellation this is about
understand even something like amazon
when they announced a couple years ago
we now pay everybody 15 bucks an hour
wow okay that's great well uh okay but
what was the pr benefit of that relative
to the cost and of course it doesn't
apply
to third-party contractors that amazon
contracts with and there's so many
loopholes and end runs around it
these are mostly public relations
decisions
and there is now a uh sort of industry
based around making these types of
announcements while behind the scenes
they keep donating to the homophobic
politicians they keep donating to the
the sedition bunch or whatever you want
to call them
and if there is really going to be
change that we want to see
we're going to have to demand more of
these companies this is really not going
to cut it
and we should all be not endlessly
cynical
but healthily skeptical when we see such
pronouncements made by these
corporations
we'll have more examples of this on the
david pakman show instagram
you can follow us there at david pakman
show don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
so over the weekend i got together
um with a friend of mine who hosts
another show
like this one i don't want to say who it
is because you know they
they may not want their their view to be
particularly public but one of the
things we talked about
is how lately we are hearing these
defenses of authoritarians from the
people on the right that we would expect
to hear them from but
the contingent of the left which we used
to call the authoritarian left and i
guess we still do
but it used to be way smaller the
portion of the left
that is sort of playing coy with and
often defending
authoritarian strongman types
is growing to the point that it is a
really major concern
i think for those who um are
really on the sort of libertarian
progressive left and that small
libertarian as in
not authoritarian not i'm not talking
rand paul libertarianism i'm talking
between on the authoritarian libertarian
scale
you're on the libertarian uh progressive
left
and uh there's now increasingly sort of
a rift within the left and one of the
things i spoke about with my my friend
and fellow host was
that sometimes it occurs to us that
it would be really great to do some kind
of an expose
about like what why are we seeing
uh this linkage this cozy relationship
between the right authoritarian sort of
populist rhetoric people
and some on the left who seem to support
the exact same
authoritarians and this sometimes is
assad
sometimes it's nicholas maduro sometimes
it's putin
sometimes it's playing koi with china uh
and there are certainly other examples
and fundamentally what i think this is
about and if
if you want examples of this just look
at a tucker carlson program
one or two nights a week and see who
tucker is having on from the supposed
left
where they find common ground and we're
supposed to believe
they are crossing partisan lines in
order to find areas of agreement that
just makes sense
when the reality is that the
authoritarian left has
always had plenty in common with the
right it's not that they're escaping
partisan is partisanship
to come together where it makes obvious
sense on uncontroversial issues
it's actually that the authoritarian
aspect of some on the left
really is not very left it's really
quite right wing that that's the reality
of what's going on
and along these lines fox news
ran a bizarre glowing profile of
vladimir putin
in ahead of joe biden's meeting with
putin
and fundamentally what this is about for
both
the right and the left is that for
different reasons
they want to delegitimize the idea
that somebody on the left meaning
a democrat is going to hold
such an authoritarian accountable
because for those on the right it's
about we just never want to
allow any democrat to appear strong
going back to john kerry and even before
it's about the feminization of democrats
it's about the these are not strong
people these are sissies etc that's
that's why fox news
would want to sort of portray putin as
masculine and
and a glowing profile advance of meeting
with biden so that they don't
they could want to make biden look bad
and for the left it's this stuff of
any time the united states even stands
up to anyone that's neoliberalism
that's hegemonic that's colonialism etc
and so hey
the the the right and these aspects of
the left
um end up wanting to similarly raise up
people like vladimir putin i will never
get it but let's take a look at some of
this
gl glowing profile it's it's almost
north korea asked in some way
uh of vladimir putin on fox news and the
overwhelming support you'd have to look
at the man who came before him
and the drunken antics seemed the exact
opposite of vladimir putin
steve harrigan lived in russia for 10
years and he's got more
on this now boris yeltsin vladimir putin
studying contrasts right a sharp
contrast john especially at the very
start when putin came in in 1999
his approval ratings for an unknown were
overwhelmingly high
and part of the reason was just the
physical contrast he made
with boris yeltsin by 1999 most russians
were ready for a change
the hero who stood on the tank in 1991
and broke communist control over freedom
of speech
elections and private property was also
blamed by those who saw their life
savings disappear
as a new class of billionaires scooped
up
state factories yeltsin's lengthy
disappearances from public view were
blamed on heart attacks
or excessive drinking to many russians
president boris yeltsin felt like an
embarrassment
he was very famous for so this is all
the build up to get to the great putin
right this is all about the bad stuff
about yeltsin first
he inibriated he was a non-alcoholic and
a big drinker
he was very large um just in stature
so the way that he behaved in these
high-level
public diplomacy meetings to the u.s
presidents or other heads of state
embarrassed a lot of russians at the
time the physical contrast with putin
was stark
and if you're if you're watching if
you're not watching they
they're running video of putin lifting
weights and then it gets even more
sycophantic
he's a martial arts champion he
and for many russians that also gave
them a sense of stability
mr putin embodied that physically in a
way
that president yeltsin absolutely did
not
putin also embodied a return to an
authoritarian past
shutting down press freedom banishing
independent oligarchs
and consolidating power in his own hands
putin could be around for a long time to
come he's changed the constitution he
could potentially
be in office until the year 2036.
john he knows how to consolidate power
no question about that
steve harrigan for steve thank you so
much and
and can you imagine sandra boris yeltsin
on horseback without a shirt on
not a pretty picture yeah so there it is
and so fundamentally what
what i think is going on here that there
are more and more people that are
actually calling out
not just the right but also those on the
left who are playing coy
with these guys um i i think there's a
couple
important things to uh to sort of keep
in mind here
number one is that um there
is no circumstance in which progressive
values
align with the way that vladimir putin
runs government
uh bashar al-assad nicholas maduro
sometimes there will be people on the
left even even defending hamas it's
often the exact same people um
there that there's nothing progressive
about that and it's really important to
to bear that in mind but one of the
really
toxic things that's going on with the
left on this issue
is when someone like me for example
calls this out
i will be called everything from a
zionist even though this doesn't
directly relate
putin doesn't directly relate to the
israeli-palestinian conflict although
some of those people are also playing
pretty coy
with hamas to a neo-liberal
colonialist to a faux progressive
to a right-winger etc etc but
what i would challenge those folks to
look at is
if you look at the history of social
democracy around the world
and in northern europe etc when has
progressive social democracy ever looked
like people
like vladimir putin and assad
and she and maduro etc
and so the case i would make is that
this sort of authoritarian left that
plays
coy with this stuff that fox news does
on putin and others
they are the ones that have been either
led astray
or for whatever personal reasons have
decided that that's the direction they
want to go in
the progressive social democracy
movement looks quite similar today to
what it did decades and decades ago
and unfortunately with a lot of these
examples
if you follow the money you start to
learn a lot about why some of these
factions are staking out the positions
that they're staking out and maybe we'll
say more about that in the future after
weeks and weeks of making strange
insensitive and ignorant comments
uh related to jews and judaism radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
greene
appears to have had a i don't really
want to call it a come to jesus moment
because it relates to the holocaust
now you might remember that marjorie
taylor green equated having to wear a
mask on the floor of the house of
representatives
to how the jews were treated during the
holocaust and she said mandatory
vaccinations are like the holocaust
even there are even though there are no
mandatory vaccinations
then she doubled down on the analogy but
later denied ever having made it
but now marjorie taylor greene visited
the holocaust museum in washington dc
and then made a statement that you know
what she was wrong
she apologizes the holocaust was really
very bad
and there's nothing comparable to it
presumably meaning mask wearing is not
like the holocaust and vaccinations are
not like the holocaust
check this out this is marjorie taylor
green fresh off of the realization that
the holocaust was really bad
always want to remind everyone i'm very
much a normal person
and i think it's important for me to
always
be transparent and and honest
and i just want to tell you all i'm
really really lucky
uh i was blessed with i am blessed with
amazing parents
and my dad just passed away in april
but i will say he taught me some great
things
and one of the best lessons that my
father always taught me
was when you make a mistake you should
own it
and i have made a mistake and it's
really bothered me for a couple of weeks
now
and so i definitely want to own it this
afternoon
i visited the holocaust museum the
holocaust
is there's nothing comparable to it
it's it's it happened and
you know over six million jewish people
were murdered
more than that there were not just
jewish people
black people christians all kinds of
children people that that the nazis
didn't believe were good enough or
perfect enough and the horrors of the
holocaust
are something that some people don't
even believe happen
and some people deny but there is no
comparison to the holocaust
so marjorie taylor green there not only
saying she was wrong for her holocaust
comparisons
even calling out holocaust deniers and
will watch a little bit more where she
specifically says
she said offensive things and she
apologizes for saying them
and there are words that i have said
remarks that i've made
that i know are offensive and for that i
want to apologize
and i am i am just fine
and very glad to be able to come out
here and do that because i believe it's
important
i believe that if we're going to leave
we need to be able to lead in a way
where if we've messed up it's very
important for us to say we're sorry
all right so listen she does sound
sincere in a way
but it's also kind of a weird word salad
with very little emotion
how if you really didn't know how bad
the holocaust was
how do you go through the holocaust
museum apparently unaware
of what you were in for learning about
it for the first time
and you come out of it with such a lack
of emotion now
whether the sincerity is coming from her
belief that the things she said are
horrible and offensive
or the sincerity is coming from her
realizing that i've got to clean this up
because this this looks really bad for
me i don't know
but she's doing something that lots of
these politicians never do which is
simply to say
i was wrong trump didn't say i was wrong
i apologize
once in four years so i give her credit
for that but
i don't really know that she didn't mean
it when she said it i think when she
said that stuff about masks and
vaccinations on the holocaust
i think she did mean it and we're
getting into evaluating what's in her
mind and that's really tough
but how does a 47 year old woman get to
be 47 years old and not know how bad the
holocaust was and this is what gives me
the most pause
great she's zoning up she's saying she
was wrong she's apologizing that's
that's a great thing
but how does a 47 year old american
who as far as i know went to school not
realize
how bad the holocaust was and think up
until age 47
that wearing a mask at arby's is sort of
like the holocaust in any way and then
you learn you're wrong at age 47
if you're really that ignorant you have
no business being a member of congress
if you're not that ignorant and you're
lying to save yourself
you also have no business being a member
of congress don't most american children
know by age
10 how bad the holocaust was and if by
age 10 you only had an idea
by age 20 don't you really know how bad
the holocaust was
and even if at age 20 you skipped class
on that day
by age 30 don't you understand it
totally and completely
how do you arrive at age 47 with such
little idea about it
that she thought masks were sort of like
the holocaust
until she visited the holocaust museum
come on guys something about this
stinks to high heaven let me know what
you think um
i am curious to hear your thoughts what
if any of this is actually sincere
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow
alright so it's been mostly you know
kind of a serious downer of a show today
in some sense i want to go through a
couple things that are a little bit
lighter although not particularly less
disturbing i guess depending on your
perspective about the types of people
that
are or have been in prominent positions
of power
you may remember donald trump's former
press secretary kaylee
mcinanni she was one of trump's many
press secretaries and one of the things
that happened on the first
day that she addressed or answered
questions in the press briefing room was
that
she said she was never going to lie to
the press corps she was asked
will you tell us today you will not lie
to us and she said
no i will not and of course almost
exclusively she lied for donald trump
day
after day after day she recently spoke
at a turning point usa
event it was a really strange event but
the
highlight was her saying she never did
lie
as the white house press secretary and
it was because of her
faith and because of god that she didn't
lie
you this you have to see take a look and
then there was the question
will you ever lie to us and i said
without hesitation no
and i never did she certainly didn't
hesitate
but she did lie women of faith as a
mother of baby blake
as a person who meticulously prepared at
some of the world's hardest institutions
i never lied i sourced my information
nobody who went to harvard ever lies
right i mean that
that's no no religious person or harvard
graduate
would ever tell an untruth information
but that will never stop the press
from calling you a liar also
lying will make it so that people call
you a liar
which is why my dad said kayla you've
got to come up with a motto for your
press shop and i did and our motto was
this
offense only because
[Music]
wow because i knew what we were up
against
republicans always get the bad headlines
always get the false stories always get
the
lies if i can use that word told by the
press there is one standard for
democrats
and another for republicans yeah so okay
so basically she
she wants us to believe she never told a
lie at all
uh while she was donald trump's white
house press secretary i actually it's
it's almost everything is backwards i
have a hard time remembering
a more dishonest press secretary i
i i don't know who it would be if you
said who was a more dishonest press
secretary than kaylee mcinanni
i don't know that i can think of one
here is kaylee just as a few examples
telling us
covid affects virtually
nobody remember this gem we follow up
last night the president said
at one of his rallies about the virus i
think he was talking about younger
americans he said it affects virtually
nobody
by the way over your schools everybody
open your schools
but he said to bob woodward it's not
just old
it's not just older people it's young
people too
at 200 000 deaths shouldn't the
president be telling people the truth
about this virus at his rallies the
president is telling people the truth
and you're right
jim that he was talking about saying
that it affects virtually nobody
and that it doesn't affect young people
he's not telling the truth
those are like but you're again taking
the president out of context i have his
full quote
here and you're right that he was
referring to young people he said this
i'm not taking it out of context so i
said he was talking about younger people
quoting someone and explaining what the
context was
is not taking someone out of context
that's true
you're you are taking it out of context
because you're making an assertion that
he's not giving critical information
when in fact he is
and i will underscore exactly what he
said okay so complete
and total liar all the time here's
another one
where kaylee says trump never downplayed
the virus
even though trump told bob woodward i
publicly downplayed the virus take a
look
because i don't want to create a panic
the president by his own admission in
private on the record
acknowledged the depth of this crisis
and yet told the american people
something very different right how is
that
at its core not an abject betrayal of
the public trust the president has
always been clear-eyed with the american
people he was always clear-eyed about
the lives we could lose yeah
like when he said the lives we could
lose are we have 15 cases which will
soon be zero he was really clear with
the american people about the hell that
was coming
again from this podium he acknowledged
that this was serious back in march that
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
lives could be lost
now remember back that's a lie in march
he was saying
and i don't even know if it was march
even by april he was still only saying
we might lose 50
000 people i mean it was all just lie
after lie after lie
uh here she is saying trump is the most
informed person on the planet about
threats to the united states and the
american people the president does read
and he also consumes intelligence
verbally this president i'll tell you is
the most informed person on planet earth
when it comes to the threats that we
face
you have ambassador o'brien who sees him
in person twice a day
he sometimes takes the upwards of half a
dozen calls
with this president he's constantly
being informed and briefed on
intelligence matters
um but i'm not going to allow the new
york times to dictate
when we give top secret information and
don't give time there is no more
informed person
my friends than donald trump and then
lastly
another lie from kaylee mcinanny which
was her participation
in the lies about the 2020 election she
was trotted out there i don't remember
if it was in her capacity i think this
was her capacity as an advisor to trump
um you know she had multiple different
roles remember this one
we want to protect the franchise of the
american people
we want an honest accurate lawful count
we want maximum sunlight we want maximum
transparency we want every legal vote to
be counted
and we want every illegal vote i just
think we have to be very clear that
she's charging
when this was too dishonest even for fox
news this is a fox host cutting in and
saying this is crazy
welcoming fraud and welcoming illegal
voting unless she has more details to
back that up
i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this i want to make sure
that yeah
when even fox news says i can't show you
this guys this is even making fox news
blush
so kaylee mcinanni now taking credit for
never having lied
and it is a liar lying
about their lying that's quite frankly
all it is
and it shouldn't surprise us here's
something funny to wrap today up
yesterday was former president donald
trump's 75th
birthday he celebrated of course like
anyone else at one of his own clubs
wearing a suit with all the other men
wearing suits
and everybody was referring to him as
sir and mr president
there's nothing more heartwarming and
convivial and familiar
than um getting people to wear suits and
say
happy birthday sir mr president and um
it really looks like a hostage video i
have to show you this
when when they're singing uh him happy
birthday
this looks like when all the parents
tell their kids i don't care if you
don't like little donny
you have to go to the party and you've
got to behave
because his parents are important people
and i'm not going to be embarrassed
check this out
happy birthday dear mr president that's
a real family and friends gathering huh
you hear that and if you don't run again
we are going to sing to you
every year what would you tell donald
trump on his 75th birthday
well what newsmax did is send a guy with
a mic
out to ask people and lo and behold
everyone they talk to
loves trump you've got to see this
donald trump's 75th birthday
our james klug went out to get birthday
greetings
what's going on everyone james klug here
today if you're allergic to cringe
i would tune away right now president
donald trump's
birthday and we're going to ask people
in huntington beach if they have a
message for him yeah
today is donald trump's birthday do you
have a message for him all right happy
happy happy birthday and i hope i see
him back
do you have a message for him yeah i
wish him a great birthday i hope he's
doing well i hope with all the
this public hate going on it's not
getting to him and uh he's out there
killing it on the golf course
yeah why is this so cringy like why is
this so
painful to watch tell me why birthday
trump
and i hope he comes back in 2024. happy
birthday mr trump and go out and shoot
the low 70s today bye happy birthday
happy birthday we love the guy he's
awesome yup
hawaii loves him he hugs the flag that's
what i love about him
today is donald trump's birthday do you
guys have a message from love you donald
trump
oh my gosh our favorite news show our
favorite news show newsmax is here what
an incredible day
it's donald trump's birthday today do
you have a message for everybody happy
birthday happy birthday we miss you
oh my gosh happy birthday donald happy
birthday
happy birthday happy birthday i hope
you're doing well i'm not going to wish
you a happy birthday because
i think you're a jerk and i think you
should be in jail
there you go now that this woman i like
this is a that's a nice one the laws
that you broke what law specifically
of course you would ask me that for the
details
for the details i don't sorry i don't
have any details
sorry make sense if you could get them
one gift what would you get them
come back i can't afford to buy him
anything but maybe we could print out a
photo of him hugging the flag
raja you could sign it oh he'll sign a
gift to me yeah
so just just painful guys i mean that is
a segment that uh
you know i can't in good countenance
show you any more of that so it's a re i
might end up at urgent care from how
hard i cringed uh donald trump now 75
and of course the only real practical
consideration is
do we really think that 70 80 is going
to run for president uh
maybe maybe not we will wait and see hey
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
the masked drama will not end yesterday
the eggman called in
about masks now we have another caller
calling in about what the eggman said
about masks let's take a listen to it
together
and this is regarding masks and what the
egg man
said he's pretty much right people
shouldn't be wearing masks outside they
probably
didn't have to but in terms of
businesses it's up to the business
yeah and guess what in terms of public
transportation
i don't know if the aid man takes the
subway or buses
no the egg man lives very rurally he's
not on any subway
but guess what we're expecting like the
worst flu season
in years all right the only reason it
was down
was because people were wearing masks
that's true
fall on winter and it's there's
going to be more and more variants that
maybe the flu vaccines can't
keep up with so i'm still going to be
wearing a mask on the subways and bosses
yeah i i feel like for the most part
everybody's on the same page what the
eggman said is true
cdc says if you're vaccinated you really
don't need to wear it anywhere
what this guy says is true which is we
could be up for a bad flu season
flu season was light last year because
of all the mask wearing what this guy
says is true about
businesses can ask people to wear masks
and it may make sense to put masks back
on as we get close to flu season or on
public transit and what the egg man's
daughter said about
i don't want people to look at me and
give me dirty looks because i'm not
all of these things are true and i think
we've got to get
beyond this from a medical perspective
if you're vaccinated
it seems you don't really have to wear a
mask anywhere but
anyone might choose to for whatever
reason is relevant to them
that's the it doesn't matter why someone
chooses to wear a mask it may be because
they misunderstand the science
it may be because they want to hide
their face it may be for whatever other
reason
and i think that that's all fine we
don't all have to get bent out of shape
about this
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we are going to preview the biden
putin
meeting which we will then cover the
press conference about
uh live later this week we will talk
about
uh israel banning the sale of almost
all fur clothing just flat out and the
implications
we will also talk about the average age
of vehicles has hit an all-time high
and cars trucks and suvs
are getting older on average as used car
prices have been going up this started
during the pandemic and it is continuing
all of that and more
and i will be joined by producer pat on
today's award-winning
bonus show exclusively awards we've
invented
but we've won all of them and i think
for a lot of people that makes a big
difference
sign up at joinpakman.com a coupon code
available a better 21 i will see you
then or otherwise tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman